[Music]
the Utah Division of Wildlife Resources
or DWR shared this unique footage from
their summer aerial fish stumps a
practice that restocks over 200 of
Utah's high altitude mountain lakes per
year plane zoom just above the treeline
carrying hundreds of pounds of water and
up to 70 pounds of fish they drop about
35,000 fish in a single flight it may be
a shocking sight at first watching trout
and splake and grayling blast out of the
back of an airplane but it actually
serves a practical purpose what is that
purpose though why does Utah need to
restock its lakes at all and does that
dramatic fall hurt the fish it seems
like there must be some other way to get
the fish up to the lakes so why use
airplanes we'll dive into the process of
aerial fish dumping and explore why it's
such a vital annual practice in Utah and
other states around the u.s. because the
lakes are such popular fishing spots for
hikers and campers
if Utah's ewr didn't restock the lakes
every year they'd be fishless these fish
are raised in hatcheries specifically
for the summer aerial drops and they're
bred to be sterile to avoid disrupting
the lakes respective ecosystems with an
uncontrolled population explosion before
flight the fish are counted and weighed
to assure that the right number and
species make it into the right Lakes
they're also raised in the water
temperature of the eventual lake they'll
be put in the DWR claims that more than
95% of fish in each drop survive the
fall but how do they ensure that the
young fish are specifically grown to
reach one to three inches long that tiny
size combined with the low height from
which they're dropped mean
the air actually slows their fall
letting them flutter down and survive
impact the aerial dump practice began in
1956 but before that fish were loaded
into milk cans strapped to horses that
hauled them up the mountainsides the
tracks were strenuous and less efficient
meaning more could go wrong before
reaching the lakes vehicles have no way
to reach these high altitude lakes so
airplanes have proven to be the most
viable option these days
planes can stock seven lakes in a single
flight making it both the most
cost-effective option and the safest
aerial drops may be done for the year
but keep an eye out for the flying fish
again in July
you
[Music]